oh
did you just want me pit though that's
no that's a dangerous thing on your
shoulder hi my name is justin hmm i'm
emmy ray velantman and we are part of
the cast of the umbrella academy and
today we are going to read thirst tweets
hey
okay
[Music]
here we go not only is emmy ray vlantman
gorgeous thank you
and can act yes but she got pipes i'm
freaking out
oh thank you
you sing a safety rules remember you
were doing it the first thing she can
make anything into a beautiful song
listen gotta keep the music alive
justin min would you consider dot dot
dot one single kiss just a little just a
tiny little kiss
that reads like a poem sure
i was gonna say like a romance novel
that you find in walgreens yeah i would
consider a small kiss yes a tiny little
a tiny one this is gonna sound weird but
i know emmy raverland smells soft
like she probably smells like flowers
and vanilla
she does she does did you just want me
pit though no no
she smells amazing and she always does
thank you sir for your face yes hello
correct and being ben hargreaves you
truly are a gift these are jesus are so
sweet you are such a gift no you're the
perfect little girl
we haven't even had anything well they
they don't know yet
they don't know yet we can't talk about
it we can't y'all don't know yet okay
here we go had a wild what is that asf i
believe that means
as oh okay had a wildest dream that i
was in purgatory and emmy revelatman was
asking me to choose between going to
heaven or to be with her in a dimension
she magically created and like dot dot
dot at my subconscious if i just want to
kiss emmy just say so this is too extra
obviously be with you why would you yes
i love that i can create dimensions that
is a superpower but this person is
admitting that this dream just comes
from wanting to kiss you
love that purgatory sign me up
just a min question question question is
so perfect question question like
question question question he's so sweet
and kind he's
hilarious and so
handsome he reads books yes he does plus
writes so well he sure does he loves his
family he loves his family and he's on
stan twitter do you know what stan
twitter i don't know what stan is that
gen z i'm so old yeah okay and he's such
an amazing actor that's very all of
these things are true books and talents
some more than others yes oh that loves
his family
i hate them i'd simp do you know what
symphony i don't know i see this is fun
this is fun oh god simply is it true no
no no no no no it's like help like
affection they
love you
okay i'd simp for allison from umbrella
academy emmy riverland is so freaking
gorgeous
thank you look at you teaching me on the
gen z culture
we're around the same age so you should
know this
i need everyone to understand that i
will either marry justin min or die
alone no
where are you your fiance is out there
waiting find me please i'm waiting
i just opened up a
whole can of worms no because emmy raver
lampman let me talk to you real quick so
beautiful you guys are all in caps with
the yelling emoji you make me blush
she's as beautiful in real life as she
is on screen everyone
they don't know how much we hate each
other i despise you i will eat justin
min's toes
interestingly enough i actually hurt my
toe recently and it's completely black
so i don't know if you would want to eat
that it's
quite gross thank you for sharing that
okay
alison hargreaves could rumor me to jump
off a cliff and i would do it happily oh
my god no i mean alison she can't be
trusted we'd all die if she rumored us
happily just a minute either stop being
so hot or give me your number those are
your options choose wisely oh
saucy what should i choose
i guess i'll stop being hot i don't know
how to do that because i'm not hot to
begin with but all right you're such a
cutie
you know you're a cutie emmy
riverlandman can you please dot dot step
on me dot dot dot for research purposes
listen anything for research you know
what i'm saying one justin min's mirror
selfie in a suit and boom
simp are all over the tl what with any
of that anyway back to me emmy riverland
is really hot yes and i don't know i got
that one i got it
how i just noticed this also her haircut
just adds to it thank you i do i do love
a bold hair choice something happens in
season three as well oh yeah
love a strong hair look just a minute
glasses
please just get my heart it is already
yours i actually have really bad
eyesight um can you see the camera
barely i am begging emmy riverlandman to
curb stomp me while doing her riff in
satisfying oh everyone wants me to step
on them okay oh justin it's the last one
bring her home how the [ __ ] it's just i
love your con you get so conflicted when
the effort no
there's always a slight pause
just say it own it okay
it's just men so actually perfectly
sculpted like wait till season three
this is the end of the sentence sculpted
like like oh like
like i mean chiseled look at this
beautiful face
no it's not a single chin hair out of
position because i can't grow chin hairs
like five whiskers
there's 12. that's it these are just
really nice i thought they were going to
be a little more intense and i'm glad
they weren't i'm sure they exist
and we're fine as not seeing them
ever thank you so much for watching us
read these thirsty tweets
thirsty tweets please catch us both on
umbrella academy season three yep i did
season three of umbrella academy on
netflix oh yeah